el objetivo de este vídeo es que puedas
observar cómo podemos tener varias
funciones cuyo el límite cuando x tiende
a infinito sea igual es más podemos
tener una infinidad de esas funciones
entonces si tenemos un enunciado que nos
dice que el límite conforme x tiende a
infinito de fx es igual a 3 esto no
determina únicamente a esta función y en
este vídeo
mi objetivo es mostrarte varios ejemplos
de funciones que cumplen con este
enunciado y también quiero mostrarte que
podemos seguir construyendo más y más y
más ejemplos de funciones que cumplan
con este enunciado en algún otro vídeo
vamos a ver por qué sucede esto pero por
el momento quiero que pienses en qué es
lo que sucede cuando x se vuelve muy muy
grande por aquí en esta función cuando x
se vuelve muy grande cuando x tiende a
infinito el 5 no importa mucho entonces
esta función se parece mucho a 3 x x al
cuadrado
x al cuadrado y eso es igual a 3 aquí
tenemos la gráfica de esta función e
incluso cuando x es igual a 15 podemos
observar que esta función se encuentra
muy cerca de 3 y ahí vamos a dibujar
aquí una línea a sin tota con ye igual a
3 y como podemos ver esta función se
acerca cada vez más a 3 pero por
supuesto esta no es la única función que
puede hacer eso como sigo repitiendo hay
una cantidad infinita de funciones que
cumplen con esta característica por
ejemplo aquí tenemos otra función un
poco más rebuscada que tiene el
logaritmo natural en el numerador y en
el denominador y como podemos observar
también tiende a 3
conforme x tiende a infinito se está
acercando a 3 con una velocidad más
lenta que la función anterior que está
dibujada con verde pero estamos hablando
del límite conforme x tiende a infinito
y ambas funciones conforme x tiende a
infinito se aproximan a 3
y además como hemos mencionado en otros
vídeos también podemos tener funciones
que estén oscilando siempre y cuando
esas oscilaciones se acerquen cada vez
más al valor conforme x tiende a
infinito conforme la x se vuelve más
grande por ejemplo tenemos esta función
y aquí vamos a hacer un acercamiento
para ver qué es lo que está pasando aquí
podemos ver que las tres funciones se
están acercando a tres la la función
morada está oscilando alrededor del 3 y
las otras dos funciones se están
aproximando a 3 desde abajo pero
conforme tomamos valores de x cada vez
más grandes y para ver eso necesitamos
alejarnos un poco incluso 100 resulta no
ser un número suficientemente grande
cuando estamos hablando de un límite
cuando x tiende a infinito pero bueno ni
siquiera un billón sería lo
suficientemente grande así es que nos
vamos a conformar con 200 y ahora sí
vamos a hacer un acercamiento cuando x
es igual a 200 para ver qué es lo que
está pasando con estas funciones
y aquí podemos ver que las gráficas
todavía no se estabilizan alrededor de
la asín total pero observa que aquí
tenemos un acercamiento enorme esta
distancia es una centésima aquí tenemos
tres y aquí tenemos 2.99 cada uno de
estos cuadrados mide una milésima nos
hemos acercado muchísimo a la cinta está
ahora la distancia entre estas funciones
y su asín tota es de menos de una
centésima aquí podemos ver los valores
de la función y podemos ver que la
diferencia está en el cuarto decimal y
bueno también podemos observar que la
función verde es la que se acercó más
rápido a la asín total pero bueno lo
importante es darnos cuenta que podemos
tener una infinidad de funciones que
cumplan con el enunciado que cumplan que
su límite conforme x tiende a infinito
sea igual a 3 y por cierto yo escogí 3
de una forma completamente arbitraria
podría haber sido cualquier otro valor
que podemos tener
ni idea de funciones cuyo límite cuando
x tiende a infinito sea el número que se
nos ocurra en este caso yo escogí 3